so can you so sleep focus for one second
coffee maker good morning missus day
three of blog mass live mister I look
like a boy trying on away cute
the my apologies I look like a pile of
garbage set on fire this morning
unsubscribe as my parents it's
disgusting
like I can't even look at it without
like wanting to cry uh-oh here's what
I'm up to this morning I'm making coffee
like a basic faster amazing chocolate
coconut peanut butter with a fork out of
the jar because I'm just endless white
trash
I just gave my dog some rice for
breakfast because she has extreme
diarrhea true story it all right checks
out the Edit III of blog mess on my way
to podcasting I'm Diana's picking me up
in like 15 minutes we're gonna go over
to postman to do our last podcast of the
year being interesting as she gets shot
that wasn't even that camera back there
final cut I actually moved my hand
that's an old film school trick shake
your hand
each USC film school I should get ready
let's have a day let's start this day
which I only show you the things that
make me seem interesting I love you
guess what I love you speaking Pig Latin
means nothing
hi Mark nice its fragments Euler alert
I'm editing in the car
yesterday's episode of vlogmas day in
tears Jimin are underway to podcasting
okay ah look at this hanging out with
friends a friend I love London okay like
that's what I always hear in like log
messes I'm so ugly I don't unsubscribe
sorry I didn't take the time to consider
your shallow feelings about my
appearance Bachmann faces five reasons
Bachmann Mitchell's dear you can through
the podcast down they just get makeup on
boilers secrets and spoiler which one's
fake nebulas
those are real why are you touching
something like that fake
oh I made a rubber this is West world
no Bachman bug was beautiful about did
my hair makeup today and I'm so thankful
for her look what how could she make
this Christmas sweater actually look
decent how dare her de snapchat doing
snapchat I'm buying this vlog mass that
doesn't month I try to do something
catchy nice stuff because Casey nice
that's super trendy dairy in touch with
like you know Millennials and Mitchell
just ruined it oh you were in a candor
vlogmas you in perverts feeding time
guess what we have today this is unreal
guess where it's found wrong you
finished our second packets of the day
was Pete Holmes I didn't block him at
all that's a wrap on not too deep for
the year 2016 not crazy
yeah that is crazy that's that's crazy
don't think about too much not too deep
not too deep think about that base isn't
sound Pete Holmes with the guest though
Alaska so we had he's got a HBO special
that you should check out right now
faces and sounds like the antlers were
done and now this car is just like to
kind of just pieces of like Holly paper
mache what come on saw this on Pinterest
was like we can make that honey and then
put it on their car and turn into this
what I what is this do you think they're
going to Hollywood
get out of here hello oh hello I'm back
from podcasting mm-hmm yes we're both
equally happy to see each other I mean
like this is gotten real obnoxious real
fast and I get that but like can it get
more science experiment I'm home from
podcasting two excellent episodes
wonderful humans great conversation
educational PIFAN ease abounded my
makeups falling out my face I'm eating
this slop it's basically all the
ingredients from tapas with last night
just shoved into one Tupperware and I'm
just eating it like a human trough ha ha
goose and I are currently waiting the
dryer installation guy should be here
any time now to install my dryer and I
can finally just wash just clean my
clothes never in my life have I ever
wanted to do laundry so badly as I do
right now because it's just tanking on
my house like it's just straight-up stay
dank and like it's like someone's stanky
legs all over my house like they didn't
staged my house they stanky leg my house
all over it so I got to wash them
clothes there's my fun like pessimistic
thought I had to order a stacking system
so that the washer/dryer could be
stacked on each other and I have a
feeling I didn't order the right one I
don't I looked up the exact model and
make and all of that but just knowing my
luck I have a sneaking suspicion that
something's going to be incorrect and
they're not gonna be able to install the
dryer let's find out yeah in the next
clip look I love you guess what guess
what this is the happiest day they're
here they're here they're here they're
here this is what childbirth feels like
right this is what childbirth feels like
yeah oh my god I'm gonna have cleanest
clothes also a huge shout-out to my
stepmother marine it was her birthday
two days ago and I've got a terrible
stepdaughter
and I haven't called her so marine happy
birthday yeah I also I will call you
today I will I will I will
it's just 8 o'clock now I don't want to
wake you up if you guys are sleeping on
and so forth jeez well that's basically
it for the day mmm-hmm tried to do my
hair in a way that makes it look like
this is hair and this is extensions
apparently so that's it for vlogmas day
4
oh wait Hana I gotta get wait okay super
blonde will stay for you guys enjoyed
this please
this YouTube channel give it a thumbs-up
and must each Marva vlog mistake 5
railing and exciting etc remember I'm
your blog miss until everyone else stuff
to the blog man what's my favorite band
I was in a rubber a wagon and I'm on
this till everyone else decides we're
off of this I'm off this guy internet
kids how do you do this me and like
[ __ ] my neck hurts a damn my face
looks skinny
I don't know friends enemies perverts
quick cue now that my washer and dryer
is installed how do you properly do
laundry asking for me she nails it every
[ __ ] time